In 1634, Amsterdam was captivated by a flower.
Rich and poor gambled on the tulip market.
Sofia was a beautiful orphan
chosen by one of the richest men in the city.
Love, honour and obey.
I've decided to engage the services of a painter.
Don't move.
Put your brush to capturing my wife.
She's a rare beauty.
They'll say:
Look at that lucky old dog didn't hear of a
lovely young wife.
First to flower, first to fall.
Tulip business, I think it's the answer to my problems.
If I were rich I could take you away.
He would find us...
He will not stop looking for me unless I was dead.
My lord, I pray that my wife shall be not of corruptible seed.
You've been busy?
You're not in painting, no offense.
I made a plan to save us both.
We will be together.
It's nothing without risk.
I love you...
I'll tell your husband what you've been up to.
What have I done?
I bought Sofia.
I must find her!
Sofia!!!
You two really think you'll carry this off?